dernière ligne droite pour le projet de
loi bioéthique à l'assemblée nationale
pour la troisième fois depuis 2000 19
les députés vont examiner le texte
mesure phare du projet de loi la
procréation médicalement assistée
ouverte à toutes les femmes un sujet non
prioritaire pour ses opposants
la manif pour tous appellent à
manifester elle ce soir et demain aux
abords du palais bourbon pour en parler
on retrouve notre reporter katia
technique
katia bonjour vous vous trouvez
actuellement au palais un bonbon quel
est l'enjeu de cette troisième lecture
bonjour david est bien l'enjeu pour la
majorité c'est de rétablir le texte tel
qu'il était à l'issue de la seconde
lecture et surtout de faire advenir sa
mesure phare l'ouverture de la pma pour
toute la fin pour toutes les femmes
alors actuellement c'est le garde des
sceaux qui est en train de défendre dans
l'hémicycle ce texte juste avant olive
et veyran le ministre de la santé est
venu plaider pour son contenu
les débats vont durer 12h30 jusqu'à
vendredi 11 avec l'objectif pour la
majorité que le texte soit adopté avant
la trêve parlementaire du 31 juillet
alors jusqu'ici le texte n'a pas fait de
consensus puisque le sénat la rejeter le
texte porte d'autres évolutions
sociétales comme par exemple la
congélation des ovocytes pour toutes les
femmes elle est déjà autorisée dans de
nombreux pays européens mais pas en
france il ya également la question de la
filiation l'inscription de deux maires
sur un l'acte de naissance l'accès aux
origines la recherche sur l'embryon sur
les cellules souches et tant de sujets
qui rencontre une forte opposition à
droite il ya eu un échec de la
commission mixte paritaire pour
s'entendre sur un texte et donc retour à
l'assemblée mille 700 amendements ont
été déposés dont 850 par la droite est
d'ailleurs 80 députés de droite ont fait
paraître une tribune dans la croix pour
se plaindre du texte et expliqué qu'il
n'était pas prioritaire en ces temps de
crise sanitaire donc
les débats risquent d'être assez corsé
ici merci beaucoup qui est technique en
direct de l'assemblée nationale